the arrival of more than 400 happy
Jamaicans after the second world war a
broken Britain called and the
Commonwealth answered
they're all full of Hope for the future
so let's make them very welcome as they
begin their new life over here
I had to learn to eat potatoes
because you didn't have yams and sweet
potatoes it didn't exist no Sally is 94
and worked for the NHS for over 38 years
her and friend Claudette are generation
Windrush they left the Caribbean for a
better life in Britain what they got
however
we also get horrible
the names that were called
the patients
used to you go to watch them or anything
like that they would shout I don't want
any black and Nerf and they would ask
you have you got a tail
it was Cath and you know that hoods
is still there
about 75 years since the wind Rush first
docked just how much has changed today
two-thirds of people from ethnic
minorities believe black and Asian
people face everyday discrimination in
Britain
an 80 think more needs to be done to
combat racism like teaching Windrush at
school Have you shared by more than 70
percent of those surveyed
experts fill this history if taught
could have prevented the Scandal five
years ago it wasn't just in the 1950s
that black people came to Britain
knowing they were British and facing
discrimination that was happening again
in this Century to people who'd spent
their whole lives contributing
for 18 year old Joel Windrush is about
belonging and the black British
experience one she says is Tainted by
racism people have asked a lot of
questions like that do you wish you were
lighter skinned or do you wish you were
white asking things like do we wash our
hair can I touch your hair sometimes not
even asking just kind of putting their
hands in on her
so 75 years on attitudes towards race
and racism have changed but clearly
they're still quite a way to go summer
Chowdhury Sky News in Gravesend